any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded please switch off mobile
phones or turn them to silent
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available in the foyer era area sorry
members of the public
once you are of course entitled to film
or take photographs during the meeting
can I please emphasize that you do that
should you do this it is done without
disruption to the meeting and can only
be done from a designated area
in the public seating can I please
therefore ask you to raise your hand
clearly in the air if you wish to take
photographs or film this evening
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop
and for the audio recording these are
all switched on and ready for you to
speak and will be unmuted by officers so
you do not need to adjust them
please make sure that the microphone is
close to your mouth before speaking and
please speak clearly
so the meeting proper agenda item number
one apologies for Epson so we have
apologies from counselor June Lumley and
councilor Mike Wilkinson are there any
other apologies please members
no one's identicating uh agenda item
number two substitute members uh
councilor Mrs Mr Constable sorry
um for councilor June Lumley
a gender item three non-members
attending there are none
a gender item four minutes of the
meeting held on the 28th of June 2022
members are the minutes agreed
thank you
gender item five to receive Declarations
of Interest are there any Declarations
of Interest members
no one's indicate ah counselor Mr
Stanley
um just to say that uh
my membership to the radio 10 Council
thank you
a gender item 6 local investigation
determinations April 2022 to March 2023
members Andrew hanking interim director
of people and governance will introduce
the report
thank you chairman you have before you
uh the reports are setting out the code
of conduct complaints that I've received
well I say I received obviously I've
been in pulse since December but the
monitoring officer before me also
received some uh and that's sort of
2022-23
just in summary there are 13 complaints
shown there I can now say that I've
actually received 14 having received one
on the 16th of March
of those five are complete one wasn't a
code of conduct complaint as it was
dealing with the clerk of a parish
council
uh three of them are concerned one
Parish Council which
we're looking to investigate further and
I'm very grateful to the independent
person uh Stan Schubert who's been
working with me on that as well
that therefore means that there's five
remaining including the one I received a
couple of days ago
two are now being concluded and will be
concluded by the end of this week and
three are currently under investigation
still uh they are quite uh small matters
to be dealing with there's nothing uh
untoward about them so again I'm
comfortable but they will be finished as
well by the end of this Municipal year
thank you um
members can I just remind you
um and this may be of benefit to um our
visitors and the information that we are
given is redacted so we do not know
personal individuals
um that are involved in these cases or
who they are against
um our questions will be around the
processes
and that alone if that makes sense
um councilor FD you've got a question
thank you
thank you chair
um
the plane on
just a process question so page 6.6
second of the 10th 22 by the outcome
versus completed complaint was not
considered sufficiently serious to want
investigation and Merit no further
action I know this is before your time
Andrew because this was last year but
who makes that decision is it the
monitoring officer or one of the
independent people look at the complaint
it will depend very often uh if it's
something which is very very
straightforward from the monitoring
officer will deal with it on their own
generally I would look to get the
independent person involved because I
think it's right but you get that
independent view on it you know somebody
who will see things from a different
light but if it is really
straightforward but not then I'll look
at it but I'll I'll talk to the parties
involved and say I can't really can't
see anything here and they'll say yeah
you know it was a storm and a teacup or
whatever but if it's anything else then
I would get the independent person
involved and they would work with me on
that and give me the advice but at the
end of the uh of the case the decision
is is for the monitoring officer okay
thank you and just one other question
um a lot of committees we have we have
sex times where things are supposed to
be completed by do the complaints have a
set time
not statutorily but we obviously have
our guidance in the Constitution uh and
I try and Endeavor to keep the levels I
think the important thing is that you
know first of all it's acknowledged
within five working days and that's
always done uh then you will start to
carry out your investigation and if you
know that it's going to take longer or
you you just haven't been able to deal
with it then you'd keep that person
informed but obviously we look to get
them done uh as as soon as practically
possible and just one more last one as
you're speaking
um when the complaint is completed even
if there's no action to be taken or as
it says in this one didn't want
investigation people still written to
and told that
yes they are so so each one is concluded
we have a system you know which actually
shows all the dates shows uh when
they've been acknowledged shows the
investigations have been carried out and
also for inclusion and also when we've
informed people of a decision okay thank
you
thank you councilor Stanley
thank you chairman
um there's a on 6.6.5
um
number four and number five
I do understand that we are
obliged to keep
our of code of conduct and
the Constitution
um
do we stipulate that other bodies other
councils Parish councils or whatever
should also keep Tibet code of conduct
and are they reminded of that and where
we've got uh number five as a district
councilor when we say completed no
breach of code
do we
chat one-to-one with that
counselor or whatever the complaint was
and so that he understands where
or what his actions should be thank you
so this this Council
adopted the model code of conduct which
was set up by the LGA back in June last
year I think and then it came into place
in August
uh each Parish Council has its own code
of conduct or should do what we do say
is that we would like you to use the
model code of conduct uh if at all
possible because obviously that gives
consistency across the piece and also
has all the best practice in it you know
if you remember your deliberations last
June the code of conduct included things
such as uh bullying and harassment put
more emphasis on that and obviously we'd
be looking for the uh for the parish
councils to Endeavor to do the same but
it is their decision to actually do to
do that
when it comes to talking to people who
even win a no breach has been found uh
generally most of my investigations of
that sort start off with an informal
conversation I will just say that I've
got two informal conversations uh at the
ever Place uh tomorrow so I like to
start off with that so that they
understand what the process is uh how is
the steps that are going to go through
the support that's available to them
both from me and also from the
independent uh person as as well and
then it depends on then what the outcome
is if it's very very straightforward and
it absolutely is no breach then I would
just formally write to them if it was
something that I wanted to discuss and
it may be
I have found that there's no breach or I
have found that there is but you know
it's borderline so let's consider what
we need to be doing next then I would
like to do again by a phone call or a
face-to-face meeting
uh thank you
um the
in certain circumstances uh there are
parishes that have adopted that our
constitution as you very well know and
we need to express to them what our
constitution is if they haven't got one
themselves and can we do that anytime
thank you
so it's the code of conduct not the
Constitution because obviously the
Constitution's completely different like
I said we would be looking for them we
would be encouraging them to actually
take out the code of conduct I would
also say that we've also got the the
Essex Association of local councils who
would also be working with the parish
councils and saying to them again it is
best practice to adopt this you know so
we would be encouraging you to do so
yeah unfortunately the local Council
doesn't Association of local councils
isn't interested in parishes uh that
belong to the the association
unfortunately and there's I've had
dealings with those people and they've
turned around and said well there's
nothing we could do nothing we want to
do so what I'm saying to you is is
the council RDC going to enforce those
code of conducts to them on the basis
that the eilc is not is not interested
thank you
so we can't enforce and I reckon the EA
LC you know it is uh for the Paris
councils to adopt a a code of conduct
they should do so I would expect
somebody like the auditor to pick it up
if it's not but I'd also expect and I
hear what you're saying but I would
expect the association of local councils
to actually be doing that that is what
they are there for
thank you
I agree I was going to ask a couple of
questions but I'd like to start with
saying that I'm meeting with the elac
later this month so I will take up some
cancer stand these points thank you with
that they're also for for parishes is a
Civility and respect pledge that we can
all sign up so and I know that there's
been some some of the parishes in the
district have done so
my questions are is I believe
District councilors are compelled to
take the the code of conduct training
could you just confirm that and also uh
what is is being done to to encourage
Parish councils to also make sure that
from my uh and as chairman of Rochford
hundred I can encourage the the parishes
that attend our meetings to to take up
this training because
when I message you about this I I was
quite surprised about the amount of
complaints although some of them may be
not very serious at all it's still quite
a lot of complaints isn't it a 13 in
or 14
. thank you that is
um Andrew thank you
so uh I just want to start with the fact
that you talked about code of conducting
whether or not dismandatory training it
isn't but we would always be uh
encouraging members to take it up so
after these elections that are coming up
now we will have a training and
development program in place and for
things such as coder conduct training we
would be encouraging members to take it
up to the point where we would follow up
where they hadn't because we believe
that it's so important that they do take
it up but it isn't like planning
training where you can't actually sit on
a planning committee unless you have
taken up that training so we'll be
looking to encourage with regards to the
parish councils
I haven't yet but it but it is something
I could do is to encourage them to take
to to take up that code of conduct and
also to carryover training again it's
something I want to have a a
conversation with uh with the
association local councils on to
understand what their role would be in
that and what my role would be as well
uh because it is something but I want to
see
if a parish council has a code of
conduct and have had the training in it
you're quite right what it means is that
in theory I should get fewer complaints
and obviously uh I really wish to uh
encourage that
with local councils because I am meeting
with them on the 23rd
thank you um uh just to make it quite
clear There Are Places available for
parishes to attend that training that is
promoted to all parishes well I do have
to make clear is that we cannot make
them attend them
no yeah and and just to add they can
only attend once they've adopted the
model code
um Council Mr Stanley just to remind you
we're keeping to the processes relating
to the document thank you
um
one thing that does occur to me that we
do have mandatory training and although
this is not mandatory to the parishes
is that something you may consider later
thank you
excuse me I'm just one thing their
counselor Stanley
um out our training is not mandatory
yeah thank you
again we have no Authority uh to to do
that each Paris Council uh is a separate
entity Guided by its Constitution Guided
by its uh code of conduct Guided by its
standing orders we we can encourage but
obviously we can't uh enforce that
councilor Mrs Squires Coleman thank you
um further to the question that was
asked earlier
um so many of these um complaints are
regarded regarding the section on
respect and I don't know if that
includes bullying and maybe intimidation
because the the detail is not there but
um is there a case for having specific
training on those areas for counselors
inviting Parish
members I'll just I'll just come back um
just on that one um uh some of the old
uh longer term members will remember
that uh last year I tried to bring in a
Civility and politics pledge
um unfortunately it didn't take a lot of
um support from my fellow members
um Andrew if you want to follow up on
that well I think it's a lot of merits
in that you know if if you are seeing
that there are particular issues which
are coming up every time within a
complaint then it would make sense if
you could to have a focus on that on
that particular area so yes
and and perhaps if I raise it again
um next year a full
forecast I might get some
of it in the training though yes we can
raise both yeah
um Mr shepol
have you heard all this before for about
20 years it hasn't really improved
the biggest problem that you all have to
take on board
is that the people on the parish know
what they're doing
um Mr Shepard just hold it a bit close I
know it sounds yeah the people on the
parish know what they're doing and they
don't need to be told by anybody else
how
so that's the first hurdle the second
one is when they complain about the code
of conduct
it's a gamble which code conduct they're
complaining about is it their one their
personal one one they're found in a book
one that's been on the telly
so before we get to the complaints we
have to work out
what they complaining about
now it isn't always about respect
it's individuals
Vicara Dibley comes to mind quite often
when I'm reading these reports
and you think ah they can't really be
saying that but the truth is they do
and so when you meet them and say well
why did you say that
I don't remember saying that
and so you go back to square one but we
need an overall code of conduct
that applies or should apply to all
communities
we also need all chairman should be
trained to chair a meeting
some of them don't need it they've done
it all their lives
and until we get that in place
it will carry on indefinitely
they copy other people on the Terry
who's ever in charge of the country no
matter what party they feel they own the
parish and someone is stepping on their
toes
and as for due process I don't think
they even know what it's about until it
goes wrong
so as a group of people you need to put
it to all your parties let's try and get
one code of conduct and sell it to all
of these parishes
the other group of people who's supposed
to take an interest they never have in
20 odd years and I can't see them doing
it now
because they got the same problem how
can they breach a code when it's not our
code or it might not be their code
because all of them have got different
codes
and until we can get one code that
applies right across this District
so we all know where we stand and they
all know where they're staying and they
actually publish it to their people in
the village or the parish that hasn't
been done I think by any of the parish
councils
because if you ask can we see you I'll
uh if you see us somewhere
and that's where we start from so when
you're reading these complaints it's a
mind and you know shall we say the
officials have a slight different view
that I might have but when they start
shows like telling people to leave the
room
not politely
and you say why did you say that I don't
remember saying that if they're not in
the pub the person would have got up and
hit them over the head with a bottle
it's that abrupt
and so no I understand what you say that
you need one code of conduct
across the ball for the Roxford District
area and then we know what they're
complaining about and maybe they'll know
what they're complaining about which
would be a big help okay thank you um I
would say the actual code of conduct
does not differ that much it is still
framed around the seven Nolan principles
the changes that came in last year less
Mr Hunkin once to advise me differently
was um more around making it quite clear
around the definition of bullying
um however some of the issues may not
even be related so much to the code of
conduct perhaps their processes as you
say chairmanship chaining is not
mandatory we can't make it mandatory we
can only encourage all members to take
up such training did you want to come
back on anything there
not to come back but uh reiterate
exactly what you're saying there you
know is is that uh we are looking to
promote uh good governance with all the
parish councils and will advise if if uh
they wish us to bearing in mind that we
haven't got a statutory responsibility
for that it is fair to say that in the
four months or five months four months
but I've been here I haven't had to
advise anybody but at other authorities
perhaps where I'm I'm better known I've
been no longer then I would get a phone
call from uh the the Parish Clerk who
would say I've got this particular issue
what advice there's nothing to do with
the code economy what advice can you
give me and that gives you the
opportunity to have those conversations
and see what you can do to make sure
that they have the right standing orders
in place that they do understand their
application and you're right if you get
the basics like that right which I've
done through making sure you've got the
right standing orders that people will
understand them have the right training
and development it doesn't then escalate
into something which
remind all members and
um for people listening to you recording
from parishes our training program goes
out to them
there
invited to attend
so that that is all we can do I'm afraid
um I've got a question please uh Miss
Hunkin on page 6.7 number eight
um when you say um obviously in their
constitution it should be replied to
within five working days
this one was the 24th of November 22 but
not acknowledged until 25th of January
23.
um I wonder if you could give us some
insight into why
yes it is simply the fact that this fell
between the gap of me taking over from
the other monitoring officer and not
being aware of it until uh that date
there in in January when uh I was
informed that there was a complaint and
after doing some uh considerable digging
I was able to find it and and to
resurrect it so it was it was during the
process of Handover that one got uh
mislaid
so in
so in Ace should
you be absent or there be another period
where we haven't got a monitoring
officer to ensure that these are
responded to within five working days
the code of conduct complaints are now
filed and
better than what they were in the past
so we should be it shouldn't happen
again you know it shouldn't be lying
around in emails it should be on the
proper system with a pro with a right
bring forward uh in it corporate
services at Rochford are brilliant in
maintaining things like that and giving
you the nudge when something's coming up
obviously they can't give you the nudge
if they don't know themselves as well so
we are we have improved with regards to
that and we're looking to improve
further so there is definitely a process
in place now that these would be dealt
with in your absence or anybody else is
absent as a monitoring officer yes thank
you councilor Sandy you want to ask a
question
yes please thank you
um
I've got to say thank you to stanbul Mr
Steamboat for bringing this up he's
brought it up so many times in the past
year in year out
and yet nothing's done and and this is
the reason why I'm saying sorry
councilor Stanley what are you referring
to it's nothing that's done the code of
conduct
I'm
I'm well in respect of
not not making it mandatory for parishes
to get the code of conduct
in their selves and understanding what
that is including including chairmanship
as well and it's so many times
sorry I think Mr Hunter
explain about that
but that is the Essex local government
Association as well well perhaps perhaps
Mr Andrew honkington
have a word with the council and and see
what improvements can be made I think
there's already an arrangement Mr Hank
is going to speak to
um and uh councilor Miss Maria who I
believe is the still the chair of
Richard hundred
so that is being taken forward is that
okay wonderful
counselor uh Constable yes can I ask
whether the training is free for the
parishes code of conduct trying in
another training that relates to conduct
is that free for the parishes or do you
charge for it
too
um parishes that Parish councilors can
attend it as mentioned before as long as
they've signed up to the model code
otherwise it would be pointless them
attending the training
so I think that's something that should
be sent out to maybe the parish council
is that if they sign up to that then
that training can be made available to
them free of charge and maybe that's
something that can be it is sent out
again yeah it is and it will be sent out
the the new Municipal year again with
the training
but any other questions
thank you um they're members there is
one recommendation set out at paragraph
a 4.1
and it says that the summary of
complaints and determinations for the
period of April 2022 to March 2023 be
received is that noted members
thank you
um that members concludes the business
for this evening thank you very much for
um coming along to the meeting thank you
and it is 755